觉得这事儿啊，
要尊重自己的内心，
如果你的内心是还渴望，
比如说男女关系，
渴望那个亲密的行为的，
那要尊重自己啊，
前提条件是什么呢？
就是分开了之后，
物质条件上各方面上也不差事儿，
如果说没想好，
我感觉他对孩子也挺好的，
钱也给大家，
就做室友，
感觉他人品也不差，
这事儿的话，
可能不同的年龄会有不同的想法，
像我现在这年龄的话，
你说这能不能安无事的过下去，
大家相安无事的可以过下去，
两个人对孩子好，
大家就当哥们儿，
当兄弟，
上下步都能过下去，
但是看你自己了，
我和我老公结婚有10年了，
我两个孩子一个是10岁，
一个是4岁，
我们有5年是不在一起睡了，
两层楼，
他住一楼，
我住二楼，
就分居了，
5年了，
也没什么沟通了，
这两个孩子吧，
就过去了过，
我就一直在纠结，
是应该维持现状呢，
还是说离婚呢？
可是离婚我又不知道两个孩子怎么办，
就是有点纠结，
那我们得聊一聊，
这5年不在一块儿睡，
你自己觉得是啥原因啊？
各种原因，
有家庭的原因，
还有一些性格不合的原因吧，
反正没有什么大问题，
就是两个人之间没有沟通，
像今年就是有两个矛盾点，
第一个是我之前都是全职带孩子，
今年我是出来工作了，
他不太满意，
他觉得我没有像以前。
咱们要全身心的投入到孩子身上，
第二个矛盾点是因为我自己也挺苦闷的嘛，
之前也没有社交，
没有朋友，
就一天在家带孩子，
上了班之后呢，
有时候会偶尔会晚上和同事我，
因为我是瑜伽馆的嘛，
就是和女同事一起出去吃个夜宵，
有时候喝点酒什么的，
他对这个很反感，
就是这是两个矛盾点，
对孩子怎么样啊，
给钱吗？
不多吧，
会给，
在做爸爸方面，
我觉得他还是合格的，
就是我们俩的感情问题，
那你今年多大，
我今年36，
在外面有人追你吗？
对外都说结了婚呢，
所以也没有人怎么追我，
其实有人问过我说我是的，
我觉得这事儿啊，
要尊重自己的内心，
如果你的内心是还渴望，
比如说男女关系，
渴望那个亲密的行为的，
那要尊重自己啊，
前提条件是什么呢？
就是分开了之后，
物质条件上各方面上也不差事儿，
如果说没想好，
我感觉他对孩子也挺好的，
钱也给大家，
就做室友，
感觉他人品也不差，
这事儿的话，
可能不同的年龄会有不同的想法，
像我现在这年龄的话，
你说这能不能相安无事的过下去，
大家相安无事可以过下去，
两个人都还子好，
大家就当哥们儿，
当兄弟，
上下铺都能过下去，
但是看你自己了，
他跟我说过，
就想让我妥协，
晚上不让我去上课，
也不要去跟朋友去吃夜宵呀去。
会呀，
他就是拿离婚要挟过我，
而是离婚，
我就听了一下他的条件嘛，
他是给我分套房啊，
还是都归他，
我觉得这样好像对我也不公平，
你俩一共几套房，
3套，
三套房子价值都差不多吗？
他说把最贵的那套给我，
他其他两套加起来跟这套最贵的差不多价格，
这些年主要是他挣钱，
对，
因为我之前都是家庭主妇，
两孩子都归他，
给你一套最贵的房，
对，
那我感觉这人人品不差呀，
可能就没感情，
我物他干他的，
我干我的，
没什么交流，
说话也就是因为孩子，
那你感觉他有下家吗？
他可能是因为身体原因吧，
就是他支棱不起来了，
你晚上出去的话他就可紧张了，
我和同事去参啥的，
我才给你发视频配发照片，
但是他就是想让我跟以前一样，
没有工作，
没有朋友，
在家呆着，
那是他的理想状态，
我也能理解你，
你毕竟你才36岁，
如果说你有一天你真的有好的下家了，
你真的想跟别人组建家庭了，
你分开了之后，
你能不能过更好，
你那个时候再考虑，
你现在都不用考虑要跟他分的问题，
可是我觉得这样就会给自己埋雷啊，
累点会越来越多。
你如果有一天他发现我跟别人搞暧昧了或者干嘛了，
那就是过错关遇在我了，
那你实话实说，
现在是不是有眉目了？
没有眉目，
已婚的状态谁会追我？
没有眉目的话就先这样过呗，
有眉目了再说呗。
我就想他提的这个条件我能不能接受，
他说离婚分一套房，
给我两个孩子抚养钱。
他其实我觉得挺好的呀，
一个月能，
就是在兼顾孩子的情况下，
我一个月能赚六七千，
那挺好的呀，
就是说退一步价，
如果真的离这个条件是可以接受的是吗？
是啊，
因为一套房子归你，
两套房子归他，
跟这房子加起来价格差不多，
还有存款吗？
他还办了个厂，
但是他厂的法人是他爸妈，
然后厂里的流水和个人账户也是有点不清楚的，
大概一年能挣多少钱呀，
100多万吧，
他有多少存款呀，
他没有存款，
他都是银行贷款办公厂的，
这种你想分他的财产也比较难，
我觉得这个厂这个财产我没有去打算了，
主要这个孩子方面，
我觉得两个孩子都归他的话，
我心里有点过不去，
你反正你也是在当地生活嘛，
比方说见不着，
但是我之前也问过一个律师，
他是说这个抚养权问题，
其实孩子到18岁都不属于任何人了，
如果抚养权都在他，
他以后会不会找各种借口不让我见啊？
或者他的父母会不会在孩子面前就是长期的挑拨关系，
让孩子不跟我亲近啊？
这都有可能，
你不离，
你这公公婆婆不是这样挑拨关系吗？
这个事儿我跟我妈和我哥说了一下，
我哥是不支持我离，
他说都两个孩子了，
为了孩子得过且过，
然后我妈是支持我离，
我妈说人一辈子也不是为了光养孩子了，
反正就很纠结，
我感觉这事儿你要告诉我你有眉目了，
眉目的意思不是说你跟人家就暧昧上了，
跟人家就怎么么约会上。
啊，
就是你有喜欢的人了，
心里面有个苗头了，
有个目标了，
再说我，
我懂你的意思，
我老公是我是初恋了，
就是在一起十几年了，
前的几年都是家庭所妇，
我其实也没真正意义上的进入过社会，
你们一点也就说你现在不要着急想离婚的事儿，
对吧？
我的意见是先别着急，
现在这不挺好的嘛，
又不吵又不闹的，
只是没有亲密关系，
只是就是就想他也没什么交流，
感情上也没什么交流，
感觉就像自己在带孩子一样，
我感觉他呢，
要求你晚上不出去呢，
也没毛病啊，
第一人家是丈夫啊，
第二人家现在支棱不起来了呀，
第三人家堡护一下这个家庭，
人家要求你晚上别出去，
这放到哪的时候也没毛病啊，
你的安全也有问题啊，
再加上你还有两个孩子，
你晚上出去也确实不合适啊，
那你晚上就别出去嘛，
那关系不就能缓和一点吗？
还是这样过呗，
先这样呗，
谢谢，
就这事儿谈不上对错是吧？
男方身体有点问题了，
或者是干嘛了，
人家没有这个亲密的互动了，
你说女的要想重新再找的话，
有错吗？
也没错，
所以这事儿的话，
就看女的自己的需求是什么了，
因为不同年纪的需求也不一样，
记得点赞关注哦。